yesterday at the Environmental
Protection Agency President Donald Trump
signed an executive order that would
drastically cut American climate
regulations here is Donald at the EPA
we've already eliminated a devastating
anti-coal regulation right but that was
just the beginning today I'm taking bold
action to follow through on that promise
my administration is putting an end to
the war on coal clean coal really clean
coal so there is no such thing as clean
coal there's also no war on coal it's
just antiquated technology that doesn't
create jobs and Donald Trump actually
said at the signing that he's taking
quote historic steps here I agree these
are historic steps to destroy the
environment and turn back what little
progress America is made in fighting
climate change this is a huge order it
tells the EPA to lift co2 limits on
power plants it tells agencies to end
the halt on leasing public land to coal
companies it tells the EPA to raise the
limits on methane gas emissions from oil
and gas industries it's basically saying
pollute more go ahead and it also tells
the EPA to ignore research that they've
done about climate change and its
consequences yeah I think they got that
signal once you started deleting all the
climate data and by the way
fascinatingly the one thing that this
executive order doesn't do is pull the
u.s. out of the Paris climate Accord
which I'm in favor of the u.s. staying
in the Paris climate Accord but Donald
Trump promised to on day one pull the us
out of the parrot climate climate Accord
I'm glad it's a broken promise but it is
yet another broken promise from Donald
Trump I don't think he realized that
that would be a four year long process
and even if they pulled out of the
parent agreement that will still take
two years so this isn't something you
can just do overnight in response to the
executive order Obama EPA Administrator
Gina McCarthy said quote this is not
just dangerous it's embarrassing to us
and our businesses on a global scale to
be dismissing opportunities for new
technologies economic growth and US
leadership completely right and this is
what I've been saying for months now the
world is
laughing at us I know that many
right-wingers sort of take pride in the
world laughing at us because they think
we just know more than everybody else
Trump says that he is doing this entire
thing to bring back jobs listen to this
my action today is the latest in a
series of steps to create American jobs
and to grow American wealth we're ending
the theft of American prosperity and
rebuilding our beloved country yeah this
is not going to bring back jobs in any
real way ok kool employment has been
declining for decades for the most part
it's not because of environmental
regulation that coal jobs have been
going away it's because number one the
coal industry has become more and more
automated machines are doing a lot of
the work in the coal industry demand for
coal has been going down partially
because natural gas is cheaper partially
because wind and solar are booming and
remember solar jobs are at least for now
both more in demand and less automatable
than coal jobs we've already talked
recently about the how the coal industry
doesn't really create anywhere near the
number of jobs that the solar industry
creates and methods other than coal are
more economically feasible for power
companies so coal plants aren't being
upgraded some of them are being closed
down what Trump is doing isn't the free
market the free market actually is that
based on the price of different types of
energy coal doesn't make sense and that
based on the jobs that are being created
by these industries cold doesn't make
sense Donald Trump is doing something
that's anti free market here jumping in
and trying to boost an industry that is
sort of naturally dying based on the
free market so this may not be so good
for the environment and won't really
create any jobs but look on the bright
side Trump's Commerce Secretary Wilbur
Ross who built his fortune on coal
something like 2.5 billion dollars from
my international coal group yeah I'm
sure he's very happy about this oh I'm
sure he's thrilled yeah oh the
kleptocrats are absolutely loving it and
this is going to hurt the environment
even though it might help Wilbur Ross
it's not even going to accomplish the
state and
it is yet another solution that won't
work to a problem that doesn't exist the
only possible silver lining here is that
this is an executive order you have to
now start undoing the policies that
Donald Trump is referring to in the
order that's going to take some time
there is going to be resistance there
are environmental organizations that are
threatening legal action so if there is
a silver lining it's that maybe Donald
Trump will be out of office before all
of the policies are actually unwound I
don't know maybe that's too optimistic
yeah because it's an executive order
obviously you don't have to go through
Congress and there's checks and balances
there but the only thing that can really
stop this is a judicial order yeah but
you still have to do the work I guess is
what I mean and you have to each
individual policy thats related to this
has to be undone and we can hope that
some stumbling blocks will be put in the
way of what Donald Trump's executive
order is attempting to do here so anyway
the world keeps laughing at us we keep
harming the environment and Donald Trump
holds up these executive orders like
they are trophies of some kind I'd be
hiding these I wouldn't be showing these
publicly